throughout your mathematical life you
will find situations where you will need
to round numbers and you might be saying
well what situations would that be well
these would be situations where you're
trying to get an estimate on things
where you're trying to maybe you have a
measurement and you're you want it to be
a little bit less exact to simplify
things or you don't trust how exact the
measurement is so here we're going to
actually think about what rounding is
and we're going to round each of these
numbers 36 34 35 26 and 12 we're going
to round each of them to the nearest 10
and I'll give you a hint of that what
that means that essentially says take
each of these numbers and find the
multiple of 10 that it is closest to so
what are multiples of 10 well 10 times 0
0 10 times 1 is 10 20 30 40 50 60 so on
and so forth so I encourage you to pause
this video and just based on what I just
told you what is the nearest multiple of
10 to each of these numbers try to think
about that well to think about a little
bit deeper let's actually put a number
line here I'll put two number lines over
here so we've got some number lines here
and let's think about where these points
would sit on this number line so this
first number 36 where does it sit on
this number line well it's between 30
and 40 and this little blue mark is 35
it's halfway between so 36 is going to
be it's going to be a little higher than
that so 36 is going to be right over
here and if we zoom in between 30 and 40
so if we say that this is 30 and this is
40 where is 36 going to be so once again
this is 35 36 is one notch above that so
36 36 is going to be right over here
so if we're out if we want to round to
the nearest 10 to the nearest multiple
of 10 what are the two possibilities
here well I could take 36 I could take
36 and I could round up to the multiple
of 10 above it which is 40 so I could
round up to 40 or I could round down to
the multiple of 10 below it which is
which is 30 and so I need to figure out
which of these numbers is it closer to
well when you just look at that even
just blue
eyeballing it you can see it but you
could also say like 36 is only four away
from 40 and it's six away from 30 it's
closer to 40 so we are going to round up
we are going to round up to 40 this is
literally called rounding up now let's
try some of these other numbers what
about 34 and I encourage you to pause
the video think about what number you
would get if you were to try to round it
up or round it down and then which one
it is actually closer to well 34 is
right over here on this number line 34
is right over there on this number line
where we zoom in 34 is right over here
34 and we have two options the multiple
of 10 above 34 let me do that those same
colors the multiple of 10 above 34 is 40
multiple of 10 below 34 again is 30 now
which one is it closer to what's only 4
away from 30 and 6 away from 40 so it's
closer to 30 so we are going to round
down to 30 we are going to round down to
30 and notice we went to 30 you might
say hey when we rounded up the tens
place increased from 3 to 4 from 30 to
40 maybe when we round down the tens
place will decrease from 30 to 20 but no
30 is the multiple of 10 below 34 so
when you round down you just go you keep
the multiple of 10 but the ones place
becomes zero now let's try a really
interesting one let's think about
rounding the number of the number 35 to
the nearest 10 and first before we even
try to do it let's think about the two
options well we've already seen it 35 is
sitting right over here on this number
line that is 35 and once again we have
two options 35 we can round it up to 40
or we could round it down to 30 I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about this well this one is a
little bit of a conundrum because it's 5
away from both of them it's 5 away from
40 and 5 away from 30 so the
mathematical community has decided to
define what to do in the case where you
have a 5 in the ones place if you have a
5 or more in the
one's place you will round up this is
just a rule five or more in the ones
place you round up so thirty-five you
round up to forty notice a six in the
ones place was five or more so if you're
rounding to the nearest ten you round up
to forty a four in the ones place is not
five or greater so we rounded down and
so this gives a pretty good clue for
these other two numbers let's try let's
see what happens with twenty six twenty
six
what are the two options what is the
multiple of 10 above twenty-six and what
is the multiple of 10 below 26 well the
multiple of 10 above 26 is 30 and the
multiple of 10 below 26 is 20 so if we
round up we go to 30 if we round down we
go to 20 well if we're rounding to the
nearest 10 we look at the tens place
that's what we're going to round we're
going to round to the nearest 10 but
then we look at the ones place the ones
place is going to decide it and we see
here this is 5 5 or greater or you could
say this is greater than or equal to 5
so we round up 26 rounded to the nearest
10 we round up to 30
now what about 12 what about 12 I think
you're getting the hang of this well
let's think about the multiple of 10
above 12 so we could either round up to
20 so 12 is sitting right around right
around here we either round up to 20 or
we round down to 10 well if we're going
to round to the nearest 10 we have to
look at the ones place we have to look
at the ones place right over here this
is less than 5 since it's less than 5 we
round down which makes sense because
it's also closer to 10 than it is to 20
so we round down and rounding 12 to the
nearest 10 you actually get 10